اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من قطاع غزه اهلا
بكم قوات الاحتلال تواصل استهداف
المستشفيات وتقصف محيط مستشفى القدس بعد
ساعات من قصف المستشفى الوحيد للاطفال
ومدرسه الفاخوره التي تؤوي الاف النازحين
حركه حماس قالت ان العدو يستهدف المدنيين
لانه لم يحقق ايا من اهداف العسكريه
اشتباكات محتدمه شمال غرب غزه الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال انه دمر مواقع قتاليه عده
واعلن ارتفاع عدد قتلاه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الى
361 بينما اكدت كتائب القسام انها تخوض
اشتباكات بمختلف الاسلحه وانها قصفت اليات
اسرائيليه عقب مباحثات في تل ابيب وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي يجتمع في عمان مع وزراء
خارجيه عرب لبحث التطورات في غزه والعاهل
الاردني يدعو الوزراء الحديث بصوت واحد مع
المجتمع الدولي في حين طالبت سلطنه عمان
بتشكيل محكمه دوليه لمحاكمه مجرمي الحرب
في مجازر غزه حراك شعبي متواصل في مدن
عربيه واسلاميه للمطالبه بوقف الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه كما نظم متضامنون في
دول اوروبيه عده فعاليات مطالبين حكوماتهم
بوقف دعمها وتسليحها لاسرائيل
وبحماية اعتقلت الشرطه عددا من المتظاهرين
في لندن الى
اللقاء